number two player on the planet from
Azerbaijan shock we are my Madeira of
shock we are this game was an
interesting game right from the opening
did he surprise you with his opening
line you know of course he played b5
move ok I know is about this move but I
don't know how to play with white I just
play I think it was better position for
me for white and I like my position too
much I think it was very nice position
and after I play with some aggressive
moves f4 I don't know maybe I need to
play some Knight e4 F or because of the
495 I absolutely mrs. rugby Fife idea I
mean I think the after Queen c3 white is
but but after rupee 5 I of course I know
so why it is ok but after this move for
me it was not easy to play I think I
have good advance not good Western just
the hydrants and
I play some active moves and after it
was not good for me but after it was a
very very interesting I mean when I go
he can give to look it was very nice
very interesting but also very active I
play King give to and afters repeat
remove I think they probably need to
play of course you need to play also
some accurately move because if my king
of God Center center and after my
position okay I mean normally I think it
was equal but I I like my position yeah
after the opening during the game were
you surprised at one point he had the
threefold repetition he gonna just set
draw and go home and he's repeated once
repeated and they said no that's it
let's go for it
what were you thinking you think he was
going for the win I think okay I think
about it during the game because I think
he must think okay some maybe he need to
win yeah in like in much in for
championship if you will need to win you
need to play some games were risky
till the end of course it is very good
for him to play a toll a hint I I think
it is a good idea for him normally of
course maybe draw but I mean in this
position when Quincy for but now he play
and I think it was a very good idea were
correct and to play and I think he play
very good and we see were good very
interesting mostly tree and also look
back I think it's good idea it was right
training for the World Championship
Magnus is gonna be playing those kind of
those kinds of positions as well you are
a plus-one your tie for the lead still
how do you assess your overall play so
far how do you feel like you're playing
and every game you play again again
again we're against very strong coaches
players and
first game I won with Leslie saw and
after I played with such a good game and
today also I like a play where bottle
player good game I think very nice it's
like I think we both play like engine I
mean we play very strong moves and very
interesting Moss and I think we play
like like how to say we didn't eight I
am holding seven yeah because he want to
try to win every time and my defense it
was a good it is okay try to be good I
think good to be test today
alright well we were impressed by you to
the numbers two and three player in the
world you've taken over that spot at
least temporarily nope you can keep up
you're fine play I got a question for
you because I'm with you a hundred
percent I liked your position especially
in the opening I prom
I thought up a critical moment you've
just played the move Queen XIII yeah and
and the opponent play Group B 5 and you
referenced this position yourself as a
crucial moment you felt that you had
something here here I was kind of I was
it's very easy for me to suggest because
you can't take the move back but you've
been playing very aggressively very
creatively in the rapid and blitz did
you consider the move g4 here and if you
did what dissuaded you from it and what
were your thoughts exactly here because
you ended up taking the pawn and it
became a draw when I go this position I
want to play not Quincy tree I want to
play f5 move and the this is I like my
position of the effort because if I take
you need to take a five look take a five
Rock b2 couldn't take me to and couldn't
take a 5 amp in b5 it is winning
position for while I was very stressed
but it is ok very nice winning I want to
play this line when I'm ok but I miss if
I play if 5 he just take yes f5
Brook take a5 Bishop e6 I miss upsetness
move okay this looks very nice rock
everything just look back if two and it
is looks very nice I think white
position is better here but after move
for [ __ ] move I calculated some strange
move and after I don't like my position
but normal I think it is good position
for me but it was not good calculate and
my mood after they when he played rugby
five when I play Queen c3 rugby five I
just think he his next move will be look
b8 and rook take B - but I upset to
forget he cannot take me - because a
five-night is losing absolutely forget
about it
of course in normally my position very
good and yeah g4 f5 it looks very nice
very good I don't know why the only one
okay think I missed just a five-night I
think I need to take c4 and of course
430 he played to the end I mean he's
here I play I change my knight bishops
and I don't want to pay for advance
maybe he think I just want to play
normal chest of course is G fourth five
maybe is good very strong thank you very
much it was a wonderful game it's you
you're playing great tournament keep up
the good work
Thanks